even it's you on paper I would never do
it justice you have to strike you
he's funny mad but it's the same thing I
say about Theo like Theo is in this rare
place right now you know like he's on
stage and he's like he just starts
smiling when you see him he's his
hypnosis game is on point
oh I told today on the podcast he did
better than kid I was like you're an
original yeah it's not beating yourself
up beats himself up every comic does bro
I know every comic does I just stopped
doing it at 50 to do with this Sam
Harris app no I just decided I got tired
of I realize I've been doing my best and
I got myself here yeah I mean you know
well c'mon there's like a to thing going
on right there's two things
simultaneously going on there's one that
you know you want to do your best and so
you look at everything you do and you go
I think I could have done that better
god dammit why don't I do it like this
like [ __ ] what is that about like what's
this about why'd I do it like that why
not haha rework that redo this but then
there's the other part that has to be
like look why are you doing this like
you're doing this because you enjoy it
do you enjoy it okay you're gonna feel
gross about anything that doesn't work
out well everything that you do that
doesn't work out well just don't be a
[ __ ] about it right just get over it
there's a certain self-indulgence
involved and dwelling on your mistakes
that it becomes almost like a self-pity
thing you got a there's a strength and a
discipline in learning how to go okay I
[ __ ] up did you did you ever read
Martha Graham's letter the Great the
mother of modern dance she wrote a
letter to Agnes what do you think when
you ask me that question
a mother of modern dance it's timely
though it's you sure like like but it's
still funny I know because I'm asking
you about a [ __ ] how do you know
because what is this woman's name again
I'll say her name is Martha Graham she's
the great I'm gonna just it's like a
really short letter but she wrote this
she was a
great choreographer she created a modern
dance she was basically like it's not
just there's not just ballet let's how
about just moving naturally and doing
crazy [ __ ] bring up Martha Graham she's
got 80 she was dancing but she was a
she's a giant she's an innovator she's a
giant that being when you think of dance
she might be the most famous one of the
most famous names ever in dance okay
whatever
but uh she wrote this letter and I think
you'll appreciate this it's really short
there's a vitality a lifeforce a
quickening that is translated through
you into action and because there is
only one of you in all time this
expression is unique if you block it it
will never exist through any other
medium and be lost the world will not
have it it has B and it is not your
business
to determine how good it is nor how
valuable it is know how it compares with
other expressions it's your business to
keep it yours
clearly indirectly and keep the channel
open you don't even have to believe in
yourself or your work you have to keep
open and aware directly of the urges
that motivate you keep the channel open
no artist is pleased there was no
satisfaction whatever at any time there
was only a queer divine dissatisfaction
a Blessed unrest that keeps us marching
and makes us more alive than the others
damn that's beast [ __ ] how about that
that's on the money anything is that a
woman that's her that's her she was
doing this nobody understood you send me
that yes because I'm so high I'm not
gonna remember it really into what she's
doing here but appreciate her words it's
like I feel like you shouldn't show me
this was a no no this wasn't a time when
they were only doing she was doing the
craziest [ __ ] this is how I dance if I
really hurt my back isn't like 1943 if
I'm not mistaken again I took 43 people
were probably struggling then for
freedom from the orthodoxy struggling to
express themselves in different ways